go introduce with your image the story
of Game of Thrones has already been
written down and is this whole time
being narrated by Cemil tirely and
season 7 might have confirmed it
basically Game of Thrones will then be
told Sam who would be portrayed by
george RR martin looking up from a book
as he finally reads the whole story to
john child before i show you a strong
hint from the second episode of season 7
that is going favor to this theory let
me firstly briefly introduce with the
whole thing about same being the
narrator of Game of Thrones basically I
came up to this while reading John
Bradley's interview Cenac today portrays
Cemil Tarly long story short Bradley
came up with a theory based on the
object in Game of Thrones opening
credits that is identical 2d as his cell
gyroscope that is hanging inside the
Citadel John Bradley theorized and might
have even figure out the game of Thrones
ending Bradley said I think it could
mean any number of things one theory is
that we're seeing now and have
experiences Sam telling the story of
Game of Thrones if you take the logic of
the story now the story of Westeros and
the story of the battle for the Iron
Throne it would be a book in that
library the visual motif of that is
you're about to be told a story the
sense of an idea of being told a story
and people gaining that knowledge the
way Sammy's absorbing knowledge in the
library each episode of Game of Thrones
has started the same way ever since the
show begins seven years ago with the
same opening credits while we have
always been wondering what one
particular object looks like mechanical
son is the origin of this and one more
object has finally been revealed in the
season six finale
you
Sam finally entered the library in there
it is chandelier looking contraption
that looks exactly like the s relates an
object from the opening credits that
we've been watching for seven years in
all 67 episodes before I explain you
what is the purpose of this chandelier
looking contraption which name is
actually astrolabe let me first
introduce with its purpose in the
opening credits as it can be seen the
creators of title sequence decided to
place the map on the inner surface of a
sphere at a nester ellipse an object at
the center the camera would then visit
different parts of the map while
illustrations on the astrolabe covered
some of the backstory to the show as we
all know the game of Thrones title
sequence introduces every episode and
changes depending on the locations
visited in that particular episode the
opening credits consist of
three-dimensional map of the world with
the continents of Westeros and Essos
located on the inner surface of a sphere
at the center of a sphere the light
source effectively a Sun surrounded by
an astrolabe like arrangement of
rotating rings the sequence opens with a
close-up of the Sun and the astrolabe
surrounding it of the most interesting
parts are really details they're visible
and has truly been both Game of Thrones
opening credits and in the world's
greatest library since those two are
actually the same object early details
on the table jecht is showing a volcano
destroying the city while dragon washes
own and several people escaping in a
boat a reference to the doom of Valyria
and the Targaryen escape from it after a
few moments there's another close-up of
the detail on the astrolabe this time
showing the stark direwolf Lannister
lion Baratheon stag engaging the
Targaryen dragon in combat reference to
Robert's rebellion the last close-up of
the relief detail on the astrolabe which
is also the ending of the title
sequences now showing the animals
representing the various noble houses of
Westeros bowing to the victorious brothy
on stack the Game of Thrones logo then
appears over the astrolabe with the
heads of a dragon wolf lion and stag
emerging from this side of the logo long
story short yesterday banned the
changing map of Westeros that we see
before every single episode in his
theory will represent the unfolding of a
story being told by Sam himself now for
all of it there are still wondering
why's that thing from the opening
credits by the name of astrolabe also in
the library located in Old Town it's
actually pretty simple so let me explain
it to you in a few sentences just as it
looks like at first glance one of its
functions is to reflect sunlight from
the window high above around the room
over mirrors because the Masters who
used and maintained library would never
ask a min candles anywhere near the
books however the most important
function of astrolabe or more accurately
or formular sphere is to locate and
predict positions of the stars and
planets in order to provide local
and more dysfunctions of the tremendous
opponents were the Masters of the
Citadel as it helps them to determine
when the long season so Westeros
officially beginning and about which
they are informing the castles and
cities of the Seven Kingdoms by sending
out white Ravens to share the news
anyways it's also important to highlight
that when samurai did Citadel he was
created by maester he uses a distinctive
pair of glasses to read the text in
front of him
those glasses to be exact its lenses via
most probably seen in each episode of
Game of Thrones in the opening credits
as we can see in every title sequence
while zooming in on the city of King's
Landing and while zooming out of the
world map is actual central lenses that
appears to be just like those glasses
now let's see how this theory might have
been confirmed or at least hinted in
season 7 while arch mystery burrows and
Sam were gathering books in the central
library archmaester said a line that
seems to be a strong hint for central
being the narrator of Game of Thrones
might be useful
thousands of dreadful writers with an
excellent researcher this one
mr. fool was quite the opposite of
brilliant stylist who invented off the
stories he tells I wanted to ask you're
going to write histories Tarly you have
to do the research if you want be able
to read your histories you need a bit of
style I'm not writing a chronicle of the
wars following the death of King Robert
the first so he can sit on the shelf
I'll read but you don't like the title
what would you call it that possibly
something a bit more poetic
we're not poet epic fenders now also
Song of Ice and Fire which was later
that they did not the age of your show
Game of Thrones most certainly does
sound more poetic this mark is the
biggest screen that Game of Thrones show
might actually end with old sam looking
up from a book as he finally reads the
whole story and a small title designer
of Game of Thrones opening credits
explained why is it specifically an
astrolabe with moving parts and gave us
one more clue than supporting his theory
he explained imagine it's in medieval
tower and monks are watching over it and
it's holding map and it's shaped like a
bowl that sturdy metre in diameter and
these guys fought over it
there are caretakers of this map this
explanation raises a few questions such
as does this mean that map in the
credits correct shall be a physical map
kept in the library inside the Citadel
and scare taken by the maesters by Cemil
himself well maybe as I already said by
this theory game Motor Show would
actually end with old Sam looking up
from
guess he finally reads his tail this
would mean that all events that we've
seen and all events that we are about to
see had already taken place in her
actual written in sentence book that
he's reading to someone if Game of
Thrones would really end this wave this
theory would actually come true don't
you think that george RR martin would
fit perfectly as the old Sam who is
looking up from a book as he finally
reads the whole story to eat her little
Sam or John child or even to both of
them
while this would be Martin's first
appearance in Game of Thrones it most
certainly would not be the first time
the showrunners decided to pay the
respect Wars George throughout the show
even though this would be the most
important and the most noticed one in
fact the showrunners already mentioned
george RR martin and his genius mind
several times throughout the show I'm
sure there are a few mangas that
remember Mac and Bert the blue-eyed
giant that is according to some stories
in Westeros the reason why the sky is
blue is according to legend the entire
known world is a tiny object floating in
the eye of Macomber what are you telling
him now only what the little Lord wants
to hear okay you're super I want some
time with him
one time she told me the sky is blue
because we live inside the eye of a
blue-eyed giant named Macomber maybe
everyday would you like to sit no thank
you
some wine no I'm sorry about your
grandson are you I don't believe that a
child is responsible for the sins of his
father or his grandfather an awful way
to die which way is that
by you're interrogating me Lord Tywin
somebody if King choked some believe the
sky is blue because we live inside the
eye of a blue-eyed giant however in the
Song of Ice and Fire novels there is no
legend about the sky being blue because
the entire world is in the eye of a
blue-eyed giant named Macomber nor any
comparable fable with this being said
it's pretty easy to conclude that mekin
Bereza made a narrative reference to the
author George our Martin since the
entire fictional universe originated
inside of his head
in fact George R Martin filmed a cameo
appearance in unaired pilot episode of
Game of Thrones as a background pentoshi
merchant bearing a gigantic hat having
in mind that he has almost already
appeared in the show george RR martin
portraying gold Sam the last scene of
Game of Thrones most certainly doesn't
seem to be out of the realm of
possibilities additionally during one
interview George noted that if he were
in the story he'd probably be similarly
he's a great character George said
Tyrion might be who I want to be but Sam
is probably closer to who I actually am
the fat kid who likes to read books and
doesn't like to go up a lot of stairs
altogether this jon Pareles theory the
support with of your prose definitely
sounds interesting and what better way
to end game of Thrones than with George
are marked